la ville de la verrière vient de voter
son budget un budget difficile qui amène
l'équipe dirigeante a pointé du doigt
les choix du gouvernement mais aussi de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines dans un communiqué de presse le
maire annonce que l'état a baissé de 400
mille euros ces dotations et que la
communauté d'agglomération de saint
quentin a réduit ses aides de 180000
euros
il parle donc cette fois ci d'un budget
de résistance pour sa ville on écoute le
maire nous nous avons essayé de monter
un budget qui nous permette de préserver
l'essentiel avec une autre pression
fiscale qui va augmenter il est vrai un
peu limité mais qui augment mais aussi
de pouvoir garder le maximum de services
grâce à une gestion plus rigoureuse de
la dépense donc pas qu'elle n'était pas
certaine gestion rigoureuse mais qu'il
faut encore améliorer
recentré un peu le dépense et puis la
recherche de recettes nouvelles auprès
de partenaires publics privés pour
pouvoir garantir la qualité de nos
services